the little prince has really come to
like this little body that's orbiting
him he knows at what distances orbits it
knows how fast it goes and I think the
little prince fell in love with that
little body and now he wants to see it
all the time as it goes around the
asteroid but the little prince just
wants to keep sitting there it he
doesn't want to move so how fast does
yeah is does the asteroid need to rotate
so that the little prince will always
see the body as it rotates around him
well for that we need to simply consider
that the period of the little body going
around the asteroid needs to be the same
as the asteroid rotation period so we're
going to call that ta4 asteroid and well
if we want to know at what distance that
works out then we're going to use
Kepler's laws here again and we're going
to have that the radius of between the
body and asteroid will be G 1 over 4pi
squared and now we have ta squared in
here and the third root of that so all
of these wonderful quantities make the
little prints really happy